what's up believe nation today I want to
do a special video talking about
something really practical was getting
to the nitty-gritty here front of the
business and I'm gonna talk about the
seven ways to dominate a local market
with your business sometimes a lot of
entrepreneurs write in me seeing I have
a local business on my market is not
online it's not YouTube it's not
internet sales I'm trying to land local
clients I want people to come to my
store I don't want a client across the
country I want somebody who's right next
to me and so being the owner of the
largest salsa vein school in the country
maybe in North America I want to share
some of my advice as well as seeing
other entrepreneurs have success on
seven different ways that you could
dominate your local market and hopefully
it helps you guys build your local
businesses so number one is win at local
SEO this is super important when
somebody is trying to find a salsa dance
class a restaurant a plumbing service
whatever it is one of the first places
they go to is online they go to google
and type in best salsa classes toronto
salsa dance classes toronto whatever it
is and you want your content to show up
but it starts with creating really good
content right so you want to create a
website that has lots of content you
want a content creation strategy it's
not just your page and the services you
sell and your bell page it's a great
start but you need to have a content
strategy Google loves content and you
need to understand that now you've
become a media company right you need to
not just tell your story but provide
advice if people see you provide an
advice that you're friendly that you're
knowledgeable that you know what you're
talking about that you know you can help
then they're going to come to you as a
default place you know if you can get
that number one ranking that people are
going to click on it and give you the
first chance to win them over and so
what are we thinking about is I want at
least one new article up one new 500
plus
on your website up every single week
ideally more than once a week but I got
it you got a business to run to at least
once a week and share your expertise you
might be thinking well how do I get
enough content how do I like I gotta run
out of ideas think about what your
customers ask you for think about what
are the common questions that people
walk into your location email you or
calling you what are they asking for and
then turning that into content that
you've been you can put up whether
that's you typing it up or if you'd
rather be on video you can make a video
like this and then have somebody
transcribe it and turn that into an
article put it on your website doing
that makes a big big big big difference
because most businesses just stop at a
basic web page most local businesses
just stop at having the about Us page of
services or products page the home page
you know five six seven eight pages and
that's it where you want to create page
after page after page after page and it
will help you win a lot of the longtail
content searches especially if you're a
brand new site people may have been
around for years you may not get the
number one keyword yet but you'll win
and all the other longtail keywords all
the other more obscure searches you'll
get all of those and it'll lead to sales
for you so it's super important you have
a content strategy and you win at the
local SEO game
[Music]
number two has used local media using
local media is massively powerful I'd be
connecting with don't worry about the
New York Times and The Wall Street
Journal and all that stuff and that can
help that can help with your branding if
you get into the New York Times you can
put that on your home page and say yes
featured in the New York Times but if
you want to get local business know
people walking in your doors then you
want to look at the local media and the
good news is is a lot easier to get
those guys they're always looking for
stories understand that they are always
looking for stores if you have a good
story to tell about why you started this
business about a new thing that you're
coming out with about the lives that
you've impacted not just a promotional
piece because they don't care about that
they want a general story that's going
to help them you're making the reporters
lives easier right that's their job if
you're giving them a gift of a story
then that makes their lives easier and
it's easy to get a yes so what I would
do is make a targeted list of all the
people who could be potentially
interested in what you're doing don't
just reach out to everybody make a
targeted list understand the types of
content that they push what what kinds
of story to the right in the paper
what kind of interviews do they do on
their newscast what kind of people they
have on their radio show and then pitch
a similar story that involves you
somehow right
it could be again how you founded your
business it could be your expert advice
on whatever is happening in your local
area right anything that's related to
your industry any in any shape or form
you should be the default expert that
they want to talk to and profile you
know at EDS we've done articles about
some of our initiatives we had a little
library that we've brought in to our
location and got that in the media we
put acts of kindness on the TV through a
retail store at the front we showed
people doing acts of kindness and that
got picked up by media we've done
charity events I'll talk about later on
where we had a dance-off that raised
money for a charity and that got two TV
crews into our space so always thinking
about the story not they don't care
about your promotion they don't care
about your offers what's the story that
you can bring by looking at other
stories they've done model those and
then pitch them if you do a good job
again you're making the reporters lives
easier and a tip to help you with your
SEO every time you get featured
in the local media always always always
always always ask if you can get a link
back to your website from whatever story
because those websites can carry a lot
of authority and having that link back
and really help your SEO number three is
host events if you have a physical
location I would strongly encourage you
to host events to bring your customers
together in some shape or form do
workshops do classes host a party
connect with other associations and have
them host there right at your shop it's
such a fantastic way to one get people
into your store but also as a way to
connect people to each other and then
share that online so at Turner that's
also we sell classes you can come and
learn how to salsa bachata kizomba
whatever you want to do and then we'll
have parties and host events multiple
times per week and when people come out
to the events they obviously get to meet
each other they get to see the studio
they get to learn about our business
we'll also take pictures we'll post it
on Facebook people will tag themselves
people will type their friends and what
ends up happening is you take this great
picture of somebody who you know is
smiling having fun dancing and then the
next day and they go to work and their
friends have all seen it and I see why
you look so happy where were you what
were you doing oh is that trying to
dance salsa we had a great time we had
this amazing party
and so that spreads rapid word-of-mouth
through social media so it's getting
people into your space who may not know
a may not know about it before it's
about giving people a way to connect
with each other and then if you're
taking pictures and put them online on
Facebook it's an opportunity for them to
be able to get some exposure to their
friends and to learn about your business
in the process so it highly recommend
you having regular events on your off
hours to get people in
[Music]
number four is give to local charities I
find this really valuable one just as a
listen it's a good thing to do right
like be a part of your community give
back in tribute if you have products or
services and you can give in kind or do
workshops that help people I think it's
just a good thing to do I try that salsa
we will give away classes for people who
are trying to raise money for silent
auctions so any charity that's trying to
raise money for silent auction will give
them you know two free classes for
people to bid on and so it helps raise
money for them you know we get featured
in there in the pamphlet in the brochure
on the table where people go to those
events and so it gives us some exposure
again you can try to ask her link from
the website of the charity to link back
to you because it carries a lot of
weight as well it's just a good thing to
do right the other thing we'll do is
sometimes we'll go and do performances
at charities sometimes we'll do classes
it's a fundraising dinner event maybe
we'll get up there and teach people how
to dance and again gives us some
exposure let people know about what
we're all about maybe people see that
dances maybe we should go do that you
know is our new year's resolution or as
our igniter I want to try something new
and meet somebody you know make some new
friends and maybe meet somebody special
then that's a great opportunity to be
able to introduce ourselves and so it's
a mix of doing the right thing giving
back your community but also give us a
good exposure for your company
[Music]
number five is collaborate here we'd be
looking at how can you collaborate with
other businesses that are in your area
that serve the same target market that
you can have some kind of relationship
with so for us
we partnered up with local restaurants
where we've done collaborations where
you know they might promote us in the
restaurant we'll promote them in the
studio it can be a dinner and dancing
kind of occasion will partner up with
night clubs we'll go and use their space
and bring people bring our students to
their space and they bring their people
to the space and so you know the people
that they bring may not have ever heard
of us and so that was an option to do
classes even for me when I think about
my role here and running
Evon character calm and my youtube
channel now owning the dance
as well I try to film a lot of my videos
out of Toronto dance salsa I want to
bring my community to know about TBS I
talked about TBS on my channel not
strictly just for promotional purposes
but because I think it adds value to the
conversation because I run a large
retail shop and people can learn from
that and so I purposely try to bring
turneth and salsa into the mix of what
I'm doing and I get stopped outside tds
by fans and they want to take a selfie
or you know talk business or whatever it
is and now these people get exposed to
try to then sell so as well and so
thinking about how you can collaborate
with local businesses or use the people
on your team and their influences to
bring more exposure and business to your
company number six is Facebook Ads
I'm a fan of Facebook guides it's not
our number one way to bring in clients
but if you're looking at any kind of
advertising dollars I think that's the
best bet if you know that your demo is
you know 25 to 35 year old men who love
the Anaheim Mighty Ducks you know you
can you can target those people and you
can show them a specific ad and so
whatever it is that you're selling
especially for a local area right within
10 miles of this address you can target
specifically those people and I think if
you have a good idea of who your
audience is if you have clear
demographics on them then Facebook ads
are a great test to be able to go after
I wouldn't go all in on it
I would test it out find what you think
is your strongest target market test a
couple different creative pieces against
it and see if you can get results the
good news is is that is pretty
measurable right especially if some kind
of conversion page whether it's a
ideally it's buying so for us we can
track all the way to a sale but maybe
it's just to the contact us page or
maybe it's the register page you can see
how far people are going along the
process and if you can prove that the
ads lead to sales you can wrap it up so
right to spend any money on advertising
Despero and spend it
[Music]
and number seven is provide a remarkable
experience there's a lot of different
ways to grow business and when I sat
down with Alex from who helps me run
from themselves like he's the operations
manager I gave him a list of ten
different ways to grow the business here
are ten different things that you could
do to grow this business and I want you
to pick two of them and the first one he
picked was being the face so he's out
there creating content being the
celebrity on snapchat on YouTube you
know being the guy being the friendly
person people don't ask questions - I
said that that's the that has to be in
there because you're great at that and
that has to be one of the things you do
the second thing that he picked though
that you got you got to choose was
provide a remarkable experience
at the end of the day if you are selling
and especially a local product or
service people talk like if people come
to your restaurant and you have an
amazing dining experience
you can bet they're gonna talk to their
friends the next day and say yeah we
went to this place we're gonna take
pictures and post on Facebook and
Instagram and spread the word for you
now people come and have an amazing time
in our dance studio now half of our
business comes from word of mouth you
just have an amazing time you tell their
friends their friends see them having a
good time and they want they're curious
they want to find out about it
themselves
the thing is doing a good experience is
not enough has to be remarkable
remarkable means you're willing to make
a remark about it you're willing to talk
about it that's a remarkable means and
so I think most entrepreneurs providing
okay experience it's a good experience
right like you're helping your customer
your customer doesn't feel upset they
feel like they're getting you know value
for their money they had a good time
doing it you give them a result but is
it so good that they want to go and tell
their friends about it that's the
difference is it so good and not just a
product or service with the experience
of dealing with you everywhere from the
website to the email to the first
contact to the phone call to the coming
in to your location is all of that such
a great experience that they have to
tell the friends about it because your
customers have opportunities every
single day to spread the word for you
every single day they could be out
spreading your message for you and
they're not and it's not because they
don't like you you say have a million
other things to do think about your life
how many things you have to focus on in
your life
right now I'm sure you'd love to be able
to help refer some of your
entrepreneurial you know businesses off
to your friends who just don't think
about it you got too much else going on
and so that's your challenge you to
break through the clutter and the noise
that most people have going on in their
native their life of the thousand things
that I need to get done today I can't
wait to tell your story about what a
great time I had in working with you
because you are so amazing
that's what you need to get to so
providing the good experiences in a
mouth it has to be remarkable
so those are my seven ways on how to
dominate a local market I hope you guys
enjoy I'd love to know what did you
think was a valuable what was your
favorite tip leave it down in the
comments below also if you feel like I'm
missing some you wanna eat 910 that you
want to add to the list put it down in
the comments I'm gonna join in
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love guys
as he said